so with rebel heart films the you know
the classes that you are teaching across
the country
you have a video or two that talk about
you know what you're offering it shows a
prior class or two
and you say that you feel that the
studio system does not want the little
guy to tell stories
how do we compete in a marketplace with
such beautiful personal films as
obsolete
is and this other film that you're
making and others that we've seen
but how do we compete as filmmakers with
franchises and
sequels can i just jump in right now and
just say
you can't yeah i was gonna say let's
lose the idea of competing
okay you know you're offering something
completely different
okay so you know yeah and i think you
know connecting with people finding i
mean
meaningful connections with other human
beings and it's not about competing with
studios
you know you're creating your own work
and and putting your heart into it and
offering it out for people to share and
they
there is a an element of the fact that
they want to
keep the lion's share of the marketplace
and they don't want to
allow anybody to come in and feed from
that table but
the fact of the matter is is that
creativity
has always found a way to um
rise to the top and filmmakers
good filmmakers and good storytellers
will find a way to rise
to the top and they
they don't want that to happen unless
it's on their agenda
unless they're you're working for them
but
the fact of the matter is is that
creativity and artists and writers
directors
they always find a way to
out create the problems or the obstacles
that are put in front of them
and that in essence is the whole idea of
independent filmmaking
you out create the obstacles in order to
be able to still
get across this very
small independent stories that
speak to people and that they really
feel
connected to and that's that's something
that
comes from true autism you know i mean
that's it and i think this is one of the
things that's interesting like i feel
like
um a lot of people are aware like
studios don't hire very many women to
direct movies i think the rate last year
was seven percent
of studio movies were directed by women
they don't hire people of color
you know the kinds of movies the kind of
stories they want to tell or you know
again maybe have a certain agenda or
something and so i feel like it's
you know like it's just very important
to me like i feel somebody i just
the other voices are hard have the
chance to be heard
it's very important for audiences to
seek out those other voices and support
them
you know like people always talk about
well we need more films by women i'm
like well you have to support them
you know like it's that thing about
being the change you know and really
endeavoring to
to give money to the projects that you
feel you know reflect your own values
um i i feel like right now
there's an amazing possibility for
independent filmmakers it didn't even
exist five years ago never mind 10 years
ago i mean for the first time
you can make a movie and five years ago
we were already in the place where you
didn't need that much money to make a
movie and make it look great you know
10 years ago that was impossible let's
just say that right like even if you
um shot a film you you know you use the
latest digital technology it just didn't
look that great
five years ago it looks amazing you know
and now it's
amazing like you can shoot a film for
really like such a little amount of
money but really have it
uh of extremely high quality
visually and audio you know so the next
part of the puzzle i think for
filmmakers was like how do we distribute
our work
you know and that's the thing that's
kind of evolving right now
and that's really exciting because i go
there's now there really are
opening up platforms and opportunities
for independent filmmakers that again
didn't exist five years ago so five
years ago you could make that movie but
it was like what are you gonna do with
it now
you know other than sort of like burn a
bunch of dvds and go out and sell them
on the road or something you know
and so now with digital streaming and
this is just like a revolution
you know uh there's the possibility that
we can we can get our work out you know
and it's
really about building the audiences and
creating them
i think educating people inspiring them
you know like our friends our families
exposing people to different kinds of
films and encouraging them to be
curious about different kinds of films
you know to i find it fascinating
i don't know about you but at school we
spend a lot of time learning how to read
books
and we're exposed to like great
literature and it kind of blows my mind
that we don't do that with films
that we don't introduce people to the
history of cinema and teach them
you know really how to read a film and
how to how to appreciate it on a
different level
i feel like a lot of people still you
know there's these opportunities to just
like
to grow audiences you know to bring them
to
more you know more exciting movies
playing devil's advocate for a moment
though do you really feel
that the studio system does not want the
little guy
maybe they're just not interested in the
films not because they're not beautiful
works of art
but because they feel they won't fill
theater seats they won't
yeah i think i mean i think studios work
from a bottom line you know
um definitely like i don't think they're
they're sitting plotting how to keep the
little guy out you know
i mean they're just businesses you know
they they're like you know they have
shareholders and they're just about
sure all about is this about money
it is a power struggle in a different
way i think and this is one of the
interesting things you know because i
feel like
the films that they make basically they
they support the power structure as it
exists you know
so for example we were talking earlier
about women in films and
not only the fact that so few women
direct them but also so few films are
about women
right true and you know so i think like
again like it's something like 15
of speaking parts are women even though
50 of the audience out there is women
and you know and i feel like studios
they don't you know because they have a
certain
uh uh agendas in place and their their
priority their priority is not to change
the world
you know their priority is not to make a
more fair society their priority
is to make money you know so then i feel
it's really up to
you know again individual filmmakers to
make those changes are they
are studios like sitting trying to keep
you out no but do they
do they care about trying to make films
you know about minority groups so they
reflect the world in a more fair way
they don't care they want to make money
or they do allow a woman let's say
unbroken
to direct and then it's held up to it
seems like unfair scrutiny a little bit
in my opinion yeah so it's interesting
and they do allow a woman to direct who
happens to be angelina jolie one of the
biggest movie stars in the world
you know i just like to point that out
it's like it's a built-in audience but
still
held up to a little bit of scrutiny is a
little unfair
yeah for sure and then the same way the
same with um
uh ava de verney who just did selma i
mean
guaranteed this is an independent film
though yeah i guarantee that the
that the critical uh the critics who
you know look at that film will be you
know gone through it with a fine tooth
comb
as opposed to had it been like you know
a regular old you know guy
i mean the bottom line is right now like
if you care about a certain kind of
cinema
uh it's not going to be made through the
studio system you know if you're into
like generally speaking you know
something that's like a little bit more
experimental or
you know more female driven that's more
that's more character based
in fact yeah you know the studios as
we're
you know as as we all know are not
really making those kind of films and so
you have to find a way to make it
yourself
outside outside of that system yeah